This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 1968, George Soi stepped off a plane from Hong Kong and into the San Francisco International Airport. It was his first time on American soil. At 22 years old, he had left his homeland of China and traveled across the ocean to build a new life for himself and his young life in this land of opportunity. When immigrants first come to the US, and this is such an old trope and an old story that you expect, you know, the streets are paved with gold. This is Bonnie Toy, George's daughter. She's also the author of a book
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。1968年，佐治·索伊（George Soi）走下从香港飞来的飞机，踏上了旧金山国际机场。这是他第一次踏上美国的土地。当时22岁的他离开了祖国中国，跨越大洋来到这片机遇之地，为自己和年轻的生活开启新篇章。当移民初次来到美国时——这是一个非常老套的桥段和故事，以至于你会期待——你知道的，这里街道铺满黄金。这是佐治的女儿邦妮·托伊（Bonnie Toy）的话。她也是一本书的作者
about American Chinatowns. Even today, Chinese people still call San Francisco gumsan, meaning gold mountain. This is where you find your fortune in San Francisco. George Toys very first stop in San Francisco. His very first stop in America, like generation upon generation of Chinese immigrants before him,
关于美国的唐人街。即使在今天，华人仍然把旧金山叫做“金山”，意思是黄金之山。这就是你在旧金山发财的地方。佐治·索伊在旧金山的头一站。他在美国的头一站，就像在他之前的一代又一代中国移民一样，
was San Francisco's Chinatown. And he was not impressed. To George San Francisco's Chinatown felt out of date. All the things he saw in Chinatown, these pagoda roofs, these dragon gates, these flourishes that, you know, to us signal China and Chinese-ness, they were things that he actually hadn't seen in back in China for years and years and years, and they were not used in that architectural vernacular back there. And so he wondered how Chinatown in this, you know, really supposedly modern America was why did it feel older than the oldest parts of Hong Kong where he grown up?
是旧金山的唐人街。但他并没有留下深刻印象。对佐治来说，旧金山的唐人街感觉很过时。他在唐人街看到的那些东西，这些宝塔屋顶、这些龙门、这些装饰，你知道的，对我们来说它们象征着中国和中国特色，实际上是他在中国本土已经多年未见的东西，而且那里的建筑白话中并不使用这些。所以他不禁纳闷，为什么这个所谓的、极其现代的美国唐人街，为什么感觉比他长大的香港最古老的部分还要老旧？
Because it was designed that way. That's producer Chelsea Davis. For George Soi and many other Chinese immigrants, San Francisco's Chinatown and the China towns in a lot of American cities, they don't look much like the China they know. It looks like a bit of a movie set actually. It's so out of context to anything else next to it on either side. That's filmmaker Felicia Lowe. She made a documentary about San Francisco's Chinatown. Walking around Chinatown together, we passed Bank of America E.T.M.s guarded by gold dragons,
因为它是被设计成这样的。这是制作人切尔西·戴维斯（Chelsea Davis）。对于佐治·索伊和许多其他中国移民来说，旧金山的唐人街以及许多美国城市的唐人街，看起来并不太像他们所熟知的中国。它实际上看起来有点像电影布景。它和两旁的其他任何东西都格格不入。这是电影制作人费利西亚·洛（Felicia Lowe）。她拍了一部关于旧金山唐人街的纪录片。一起漫步唐人街时，我们路过了由金龙守护的美国银行（Bank of America）自动取款机，
shops with neon lit names like Heart of Shanghai, selling paper fans and plastic booties, and towering four-story bazaars crowned with little pagodas. But Chinatown hasn't always looked this way. In fact, before the massive earthquake that leveled San Francisco in 1906, Chinatown looked like most of the other neighborhoods in San Francisco. Rose of brick homes done up with Victorian Italian art facades. The only thing you recognize is Chinatown are the people in it,
挂着霓虹灯招牌的店铺，比如“上海之心”（Heart of Shanghai），出售纸扇和塑料短靴，还有头顶小宝塔的四层高耸集市。但唐人街并非一直都是这个样子的。事实上，在1968年（应为1906年）将旧金山夷为平地的巨大地震之前，唐人街看起来就像旧金山的绝大多数其他社区一样。一排排红砖房饰以维多利亚式和意大利艺术风格的外墙。你唯一能认出那是唐人街的地方，是里面的人，
and the Chinese signs instead of American signs. That's Phil Choi, a retired architect and historian of Chinese American culture. He grew up in San Francisco's Chinatown and still lives there today. He says it's not like Chinese immigrants in SF had strong opinions either way about their neighborhood's Victorian flourishes, the columns, the porches. They just didn't have much choice when it came to where they lived. After arriving in America, they moved into the old homes that white people had abandoned for greener pastures. And after that, basically the Chinese didn't have time to really pay attention to the architecture or creating Chinese architecture. The basic desire was to make a living.
以及中文招牌而非美国招牌。这是菲尔·崔（Phil Choi），一位退休建筑师和美国华人文化历史学家。他在旧金山的唐人街长大，至今仍住在那里。他说，旧金山的中国移民并非对他们社区的维多利亚式装饰、柱子和门廊持有强烈的赞成或反对意见。在居住地点方面，他们根本没有太多选择。抵达美国后，他们搬进了白人为了寻找更好环境而遗弃的老房子。在此之后，中国人基本上没有时间真正关注建筑或创造中国建筑。最基本的需求是谋生。
And making a living was easier said than done if you were Chinese in early 20th century San Francisco. Since the 1860s, Chinese immigrants had been a convenient scapegoat for nationwide job shortages. The result was federal legislation like the 1882 Chinese Exclusion Act, which barred the vast majority of Chinese people from entering the states, and made it impossible for Chinese
如果你是20世纪初旧金山的华裔，谋生说起来容易做起来难。自1860年代以来，中国移民一直是全国性职位短缺的现成替罪羊。其结果是出台了诸如1882年《排华法案》这样的联邦立法，该法案禁止绝大多数中国人进入美国，并使已经
already in the U.S. to become new American citizens. In San Francisco, racist housing policies made it almost impossible for people of Chinese heritage to live outside of Chinatown. And when they did set foot outside the 15 square blocks of the Chinese enclave, it was at the risk of physical violence. So the self-contained world of Chinatown served as a desperately needed refuge for Chinese San Francisco. But in 1906, that refuge would be eviscerated by a double whammy of a disaster. Early in the morning of April 18th of that year,
身处美国的中国人无法成为新的美国公民。在旧金山，种族主义住房政策使得华裔几乎不可能住在唐人街之外。而当他们确实踏出这15个街区组成的华人 enclave（聚居区）时，就要冒着遭受暴力袭击的风险。因此，唐人街这个自成一体的世界，成了旧金山华人急需的避难所。但在1906年，这个避难所将被双重灾难彻底摧毁。当年4月18日清早，
San Francisco's woke up to a 7.8 magnitude earthquake. It was the biggest quake in the city's recorded history. Still is, but those violent tremors were just the beginning. Because the earthquake shattered the city's gas mains, and the gas that leaked out, somewhere it connected with a spark. The massive fires that resulted lasted for three days and destroyed about 500 city blocks. Chinatown was one of the first neighborhoods to go up and smoke.
旧金山人被一场7.8级的大地震惊醒。这是该市有记载以来最大的一次地震。现在依然是，但那些剧烈的震动只是开始。因为地震震碎了城市的燃气管道，泄漏的燃气在某处碰到了火星。随之而来的大火持续了三天，摧毁了大约500个城市街区。唐人街是化为灰烬的首批社区之一。
The safe space for Chinese release that 15 block radius of the neighborhood and without it, it becomes a very dangerous situation. Andrea Davies is a historian at the Stanford Humanities Center, but before her career in academia, she was in a slightly different line of work. I was a San Francisco firefighter for about five years, and so my first assignment was trying to tell. Fighting fires in that neighborhood later led Davies to write a social history of the 1906 catastrophe. She says that in the wake of the disaster, newspapers peddled this feel-goodie story
华人的安全空间，也就是那个15个街区的社区范围一旦失去，就会变成非常危险的局面。安德烈娅·戴维斯（Andrea Davies）是斯坦福人文中心（Stanford Humanities Center）的历史学家，但在她投身学术界之前，她从事的是一份略有不同的工作。“我曾当过大约五年的旧金山消防员，所以我的第一个任务就是去尝试辨别……”扑灭那个社区的大火后来促使戴维斯撰写了一部关于1906年灾难的社会史。她说，在灾难发生后，报纸兜售这种温馨的故事：
that the SF Quake and Fire were social equalizers, that the shared experience of suffering united San Francisco's of all colors and creeds, man helping man and so on. But while white men may have helped white men, no one was up in the Chinese. And in fact, the racism against them only intensified. I call it heightened post-disaster racism. You could see this heightened racism happening on at least two levels, first with individual
旧金山地震和火灾是社会的平衡器，苦难的共同经历将各种肤色和信仰的旧金山人团结在一起，守望相助等等。但虽然白人可能帮助了白人，却没有一个人去帮助中国人。事实上，针对他们的种族主义反而加剧了。我称之为“灾后种族主义升级”。你至少可以在两个层面上看到这种加剧的种族主义，首先是针对个人的
white San Francisco's. The built environment keeps everyone in their place, and that's what gets erased on April 18, 1906. So if you're an elite white San Francisco, you don't have to see the residents of Chinatown issue go there. As the Chinese are leaving their homes in desperation, they're being yelled at to get out and don't turn back. And according to Davies, it wasn't just private citizens who were guilty of that heightened racism,
白人旧金山人。建筑环境让每个人各安其位，而这正是1906年4月18日被抹去的东西。所以，如果你是一个旧金山的精英白人，你就不必看到唐人街居民的问题，也不必去那里。当华人们绝望地离开家园时，他们被大喊着滚出去，不许回头。据戴维斯所说，不仅普通公民犯了这种加剧的种族主义，
because the second place that the fire spurred a flare-up in racism was in how the recovery efforts were managed. The fire department did very little to stop it in Chinatown, and in fact made it worse. And the water mains have broken, so it not what enough water to fight the fires. As we look at Chinatown, which is nestled right against Knob Hill, where all the elite mansions are, all the water goes directly by the mayor to save Knob Hill. And all the dynamite goes into Chinatown. At the time, fire departments would dynamite buildings to keep fire from spreading. At the time, fire departments would dynamite buildings to keep fire from spreading. But the fire department used the wrong kind of dynamite, and Chinatown burned all the faster. In the following days, as the embers of Chinatown cooled, the Chinese found themselves homeless,
因为大火引发种族主义高涨的第二个地方是在救援工作的管理方式上。消防部门几乎没有采取任何措施来阻止火势蔓延到唐人街，事实上反而使情况更糟。而且水管已经破裂，所以没有足够的水来灭火。当我们看着唐人街时，它紧邻着诺布山（Knob Hill），那里坐落着所有的精英豪宅，所有的水都直接从市长那里调走去拯救诺布山。所有的炸药都被送进了唐人街。当时，消防部门会用炸药炸毁建筑物以防止火势蔓延。当时，消防部门会用炸药炸毁建筑物以防止火势蔓延。但消防部门使用了错误类型的炸药，导致唐人街烧得更快。在随后的几天里，随着唐人街的余烬冷却下来，华人们发现自己无家可归，
and newly vulnerable in hostile streets. But things were about to get worse. So many of the city's political and business leaders were actually excited about this social equalizing disaster because it eliminated Chinatown and they thought we'll never rebuild it. Before the quake, many whites had seen the Chinese neighborhood as a Gamora of opium dens, prostitution, and disease. In 1885, City Hall had prepared a municipal report
在充满敌意的街道上变得更加脆弱。但事情还远不止于此。该市许多政治和商业领袖实际上对这场具有社会平衡作用的灾难感到兴奋，因为它消灭了唐人街，他们认为我们再也不会重建它了。地震发生前，许多白人将华人社区视为鸦片馆、卖淫和疾病的蛾摩拉（罪恶之城）。1885年，市政府准备了一份市政报告
on Chinatown and in that report. Pages of documentation listing all the houses of prostitution and the number of gambling houses and OPM dens throughout Chinatown. This reputation for vice had actually created a minor industry of slum tourism in Chinatown. Thrills seeking white people could hire a guide to lead them through scenes of alleged depravity. They would be taken through dimly lit buildings and shown opium smokers and prostitutes and gambling.
关于唐人街，在该报告中。数页的文件列出了唐人街所有的妓院、赌场和鸦片馆的数量。这种恶名实际上在唐人街催生了一个小型贫民窟旅游产业。寻求刺激的白人可以雇佣导游带他们参观所谓的堕落场景。他们会被带过昏暗的建筑物，观赏吸食鸦片者、妓女和赌博。
Evidence suggests that some of these scenes may have actually been staged by the guides themselves. And one thing that was definitely fake was a widespread rumor that San Francisco's Chinese residents lived in underground tunnels. This is what they really believe that the Chinese lived underground, and even today, people once the siege, China towns underground. On top of all this, China town was right in the middle of choice downtown real estate. Real estate that San Francisco elites had long wanted for white businesses. In fact, two years before the fire,
有证据表明，其中一些场景实际上可能是由导游自己策划的。而有一件绝对是假的事情，那就是关于旧金山华人居住在地下隧道的广为流传的谣言。这就是他们真正相信的，即中国人住在地下，甚至在今天，人们一旦围攻，就会提到唐人街的地下。最重要的是，唐人街正处于市中心黄金地段的中央。旧金山精英们长期以来一直垂涎这片房地产，想将其用于白人企业。事实上，在火灾发生前两年，
then Mayor James Fielin had hired an architect to draw up sketches for a new downtown. The architect they hired, you may have heard of him. Daniel Burnham. And in his plan, there is no churned down. Burnham was a proponent of the city beautiful movement and urban planning philosophy popular in the late 19th and early 20th centuries. And this idea of city beautiful, it's very racialized this view,
时任市长詹姆斯·费兰（James Phelan）曾聘请建筑师绘制新市中心的草图。他们雇用的建筑师，你可能听说过他：丹尼尔·伯纳姆（Daniel Burnham）。在他的计划中，没有唐人街。伯纳姆是“城市美化运动”（City Beautiful movement）的支持者，这是一种在19世纪末和20世纪初流行的城市规划哲学。而这种城市美化的理念，这种观点是非常带有种族色彩的，
and the idea is a more beautiful urban environment creates a more beautiful citizen. Like we want a beautiful city of well-educated citizens, and everyone is white and productive. And with Chinatown burned to the ground, city leaders seized the chance to make that white dream a reality. Within a week of the fire, City Hall created a committee dedicated solely to relocating Chinatown. The group included former mayor James Fielin, the one who had hired Burnham to drop those revised drafts of San Francisco. And so the minute the city goes up in flames, I'm not kidding, I don't think the city's finished burning. And James Phelan is telegraphing. Dana Burnham, send more reports immediately,
其理念是更美丽的城市环境能造就更美丽的公民。就像我们想要一个由受过良好教育的公民组成的美丽的城市，而且每个人都是白人且富有生产力。随着唐人街被烧为平地，市领导抓住机会将这个白人的梦想变成现实。火灾发生后的一周内，市政府成立了一个专门负责迁移唐人街的委员会。该小组成员包括前市长詹姆斯·费兰，正是他雇用伯纳姆绘制了旧金山的这些修改草图。所以，就在城市陷入火海的那一刻，我没开玩笑，我觉得城市还没烧完。詹姆斯·费兰就在发电报给达纳·伯纳姆（应为丹尼尔），立即发送更多报告，
get them to the hands of the city leaders and business leaders. Here's our plan, we can rebuild. Here's the perfect city. The plan for that perfect city booted the Chinese all the way to Hunter's Point, a region on the edge of town. It's where the city's slaughterhouses were. But it wasn't long before the Chinese residents found out about the plan. And they fought back,
把它们交到城市领导和商界领袖手中。这是我们的计划，我们可以重建。这是最完美的城市。完美城市的计划把中国人一直赶到了亨特角（Hunter's Point），那是城边缘的一个地区。那是城市屠宰场所在地。但没过多久，华人居民就发现了这个计划。他们进行了反击，
and I think they fought back very intelligently. They got China's Empress Dowager Sushi involved. She sent her consul general from Washington to meet with San Francisco officials. But the coup de Gras was financial. For decades, San Francisco had been a key hub for trade with China. So, a group of the city's top Chinese business owners wrote to the current mayor in a language San Francisco officials could easily understand. And so, on the business level that the negotiation was, okay, you don't want us to come back.
而且我认为他们的反击非常聪明。他们让中国的慈禧太后卷入了此事。她派了驻华盛顿的总领事与旧金山官员会面。但决定性的一击是财务上的。几十年来，旧金山一直是与中国贸易的关键枢纽。因此，该市的一群顶级华人企业主用旧金山官员能轻易听懂的语言写信给现任市长。因此，在商业层面的谈判是：好吧，你们不想让我们回来。
We're not going to Hunter's Point. We can go to Tacoma, we can go to Portland, so there's a panic of a loss of revenue for the city. And that was a loss that city leaders couldn't take. Less than a month after the quake, the mayor dissolved his committee to relocate Chinatown. For Chinese Americans at this time, this was an unprecedented political victory,
我们不会去亨特角。我们可以去塔科马，我们可以去波特兰，所以这引起了对城市收入损失的恐慌。这是城市领导人无法承受的损失。地震发生不到一个月后，市长解散了他迁址唐人街的委员会。对于那时的美籍华人来说，这是一场史无前例的政治胜利，
but they didn't stop there. The fire had left Chinatown a blank slate, and for the first time, the Chinese were holding the chalk. They were sick of Chinatown getting this bad rap for vice, sick of city hall harassing them, sick of visitors asking them if they lived in tunnels. The Chinese wanted a makeover for their neighborhood, and an American-born Chinese businessman named Luk Tin Eli knew just how to go about it.
但他们并没有就此止步。大火给唐人街留下了一张白纸，华人们破天荒地掌握了粉笔。他们厌倦了唐人街背负的恶名，厌倦了市政府的骚扰，厌倦了游客问他们是否住在隧道里。华人们希望为自己的社区来一次大改造，而一个在美国出生的华人商人陆廷礼（Luk Tin Eli）深知该如何着手。
The word was build me a pagoda. That's Felicia Lowe again. She says that Luk Tin Eli figured, hey, if tourists are always going to come to Chinatown seeking a taste of some imaginary East, let's give them what they want. And so he was able to hire white architects to create a Chinatown that looked the way white people imagined Chinatown to look, even though he knew in his own mind that the buildings in China didn't all look like this.
话很简单——给我建一座宝塔。又是费利西亚·洛。她说陆廷礼想通了，嘿，如果游客总是来唐人街寻找某种想象中的东方的味道，那就满足他们的愿望吧。因此，他得以聘请白人建筑师来建造一个符合白人想象中唐人街样子的唐人街，尽管他心里清楚中国的建筑并非全长这样。
Now looks plan might seem a bit counterintuitive at first. For decades, the Chinese of San Francisco had been harassed precisely because they looked and dressed differently from mainstream white America. And here was a guy saying, let's rebuild our neighborhood in a way that emphasizes our foreignness, that carves our difference from the rest of the city into the very face of our buildings. Pabani Soy, whose father had been flummoxed by the look of Chinatown when he arrived in San Francisco, she says that the Chinese community of 1907 saw a positive side to that foreignness. And they also were pretty savvy with the fact
现在，陆的计划一开始可能看起来有点反直觉。几十年来，旧金山的华人一直遭到骚扰，恰恰是因为他们的外表和着装与主流白人美国不同。而这里有个人说，让我们以强调我们的异国情调的方式重建我们的社区，将我们的与众不同直接镌刻在我们建筑的表面。邦妮·索伊的父亲在抵达旧金山时曾对唐人街的外观感到困惑，她说1907年的华人社区看到了这种异国情调积极的一面。他们也非常精明地意识到
that people were interested in them, and they were interested in this exotic element, and if they could build that in a way that was attractive instead of repellent, that that would be protective for them. Look hired an architect named T. Patterson Ross, and an engineer named AW Bergerin. These two men had never been to China. At the time, the architects were not trained in the tradition or anything about oriental architecture because also at that time the orient was considered way behind the west. So culturally everything was looked down upon, let's say, it's nothing to study about. Ross and Bergerin's knowledge of China was limited to a few images they'd seen of ancient
人们对他们很感兴趣，他们对这种异国情调很感兴趣，如果他们能以一种具有吸引力而不是令人反感的方式建造它，那将是对他们的一种保护。陆聘请了一位名叫T·帕特森·罗斯（T. Patterson Ross）的建筑师和一位名叫A·W·伯杰林（A.W. Bergerin）的工程师。这两个人从未去过中国。当时，建筑师们没有受过东方建筑传统或任何相关方面的培训，因为在那个时候，东方也被认为远远落后于西方。所以在文化上一切都被看不起，可以说，没有什么好研究的。罗斯和伯杰林对中国的了解仅限于他们看到的几张古代照片
palaces from the Song Dynasty, an architectural style that was already hundreds of years old by the early 20th century. But that didn't stop Ross and Bergerin from using their imaginations, and oh, how they used their imaginations. They created the sort of Disney land effect. For instance, the Sing Chong building was topped with a small structure
宋代宫殿，这种建筑风格在20世纪初就已经有几百年历史了。但这并没有阻止罗斯和伯杰林发挥他们的想象力，哦，他们是多么地发挥想象力啊。他们创造了某种迪士尼乐园效应。例如，兴昌大厦（Sing Chong building）顶部有一个小建筑，
that sort of looked like a pagoda. But choice says that in China, you typically wouldn't see a pagoda on top of another building. Pagoda's there are free-standing structures, not a decorative flourish. And secondly, In China, these were monuments for religious purposes, the religion of Buddhism. Here, in its San Francisco form, the pagoda instead houses a monument to consumerism.
有点像宝塔。但崔说，在中国，你通常不会在另一座建筑的顶部看到宝塔。那里的宝塔是独立的建筑，而不是装饰性的点缀。其次，在中国，这些是用于宗教目的的纪念碑，即佛教。在这里，在旧金山的版本中，宝塔反而成了一座消费主义的纪念碑。
Sing Chong became a bustling department store, Hawking Asian Art, which it still is to this day. But nonetheless, the designers that looked 10 Eli hired created a striking building. And other merchants rebuilding in Chinatown couldn't help but notice. Soon, Sing Chang's bombastic Shinwazari look had become the style for most new structures going up in Chinatown. The architects who were trying to reproduce Beijing in San Francisco may have gotten a lot of the details wrong. But for the Taurus, they were wrong in all the right ways. Taurus loved the new Chinatown. This was exactly the westerner friendly version of China they wanted,
兴昌变成了繁华的百货公司，叫卖亚洲艺术品，至今仍然如此。尽管如此，陆廷礼雇用的设计者还是创造了一座引人注目的建筑。其他在唐人街重建的商家也注意到了这一点。很快，兴昌那浮夸的“中国风”外观成为了唐人街大多数新建筑的风格。那些试图在旧金山复制北京的建筑师可能把很多细节都搞错了。但对游客来说，他们在所有正确的地方都错了。游客喜欢新的唐人街。这正是他们想要的西方人友好的中国版本，
vaguely exotic, but safe enough for a middle-class white America. The visitors began to flow into Chinatown, and so did their cash. In Chinatown's pleasant new appearance was beginning to change popular sentiment towards the Chinese people. American newspapers made it explicit that the neighborhood makeover was causing them to rethink their contempt for the Chinese. As one newspaper, the bulletin put it in 1909, quote, China Town is one of the most noted places on the American continent. We have held up to the public gaze for too long the racial grief that separates the yellow and white people of the earth."
隐约带有异国情调，但对中产阶级白人美国人来说足够安全。游客开始涌入唐人街，他们的现金也随之而来。唐人街崭新宜人的外表开始改变大众对中国人的看法。美国报纸明确表示，社区大改造让他们重新审视对中国人的蔑视。正如《公报》（The Bulletin）1909年所言，引述：“唐人街是美洲大陆最著名的地点之一。我们把隔离地球上黄种人和白人的种族悲剧在公众目光下展示得太久了。”
And quote, Looktan Eli's plan had worked. And Chinese communities elsewhere in the US were taking note. All of the success of Chinatowns that have come in America take a cue from this, take a page from this playbook, New York San Francisco LA, Honolulu. They all sort of have their roots in San Francisco. That's Bonnie Saw again. She says the visual style and tourist-friendly attitude that San Francisco's Chinatown had perfected soon began to spread.
引述完毕。陆廷礼的计划成功了。美国其他地方的华人社区也注意到了这一点。美国所有取得成功的唐人街都从中吸取了经验，从这套剧本中借鉴了一页，纽约、旧金山、洛杉矶、檀香山。它们的根源都或多或少可以追溯到旧金山。又是邦妮·索伊。她说旧金山唐人街完善的视觉风格和对游客友好的态度很快开始传播开来。
In fact, the new Chinatown brand was so successful that it's still influencing Chinatowns being built in our own time. For instance, take the Chinatown in Las Vegas, which was created in the 90s. It also had the same pagoda ruflines and dragon gates, like the same language, the architectural language, the same architectural vernacular was being used to create the newest Chinatown that was used to create the oldest Chinatown. You know, you outsmarted the devil. You know, basically there is a phrase, you know, that they called white people, Bacquay, which is the white devil. I think that it was a victory, absolutely. Of course, this architectural revenge didn't instantly fix everything for the Chinese and San Francisco.
事实上，新的唐人街品牌是如此成功，以至于它至今仍在影响着正在建造的唐人街。例如，以拉斯维加斯的唐人街为例，它建于90年代。它也有相同的宝塔屋顶线条和龙门，就像同样的语言，建筑语言，同样的建筑白话被用来建造最新的唐人街，而这正是用来建造最古老的唐人街的。你知道，你智胜了恶魔。你知道，基本上有一个短语，你知道，他们叫白人“Bacquay”，也就是白鬼。我认为这绝对是一场胜利。当然，这种建筑上的复仇并没有立刻解决旧金山华人的所有问题。
They still faced plenty of legal and popular discrimination. For example, they were still required by real estate laws to live in Chinatown. And on a federal level, the Chinese Exclusion Act itself wouldn't even be repealed until 1943. More than 30 years later. And even if the rebranding of Chinatown helped to ease negative sentiment towards the Chinese, Philip Choi believes it may also have helped promote certain stereotypes. It continues to provoke our fullness, and I remember my daughter coming home one day very annoyed and upset. Is it these people?
他们仍然面临着大量的法律和大众歧视。例如，房地产法律仍然要求他们住在唐人街。而在联邦层面，排华法案本身直到1943年才被废除。三十多年后。即使唐人街的重新包装有助于缓解对中国人的负面情绪，菲利普·崔（Philip Choi）认为它可能也助长了某些刻板印象。“它继续挑起我们的异国情调，我记得我女儿有一天回家时非常恼火和沮丧。她说这些人，
Look, look, look, it's like they've never seen a Chinese person before. By contrast, look at the other traditionally ethnic neighborhoods in San Francisco, Japan, town, or the Italian neighborhood of North Beach. Choice as those neighborhoods didn't self-exoticize in the 1900s to nearly the same extent that China down did. They deliberately not embellish and embrace the ethnicity. Other immigrant groups at that time didn't face the same antagonism that the Chinese did. So only the Chinese were forced to cater to white people's fantasies as a survival mechanism.
看，看，看，就好像他们从来没见过中国人一样。”相比之下，看看旧金山其他传统的少数族裔社区，日本城（Japantown）或意大利社区北海滩（North Beach）。崔说，这些社区在20世纪并没有像唐人街那样进行自我异国情调化。他们刻意不粉饰和拥抱民族特色。当时的其他移民群体没有面临与中国人相同的对立。因此，只有中国人才被迫迎合白人的幻想作为生存机制。
Well, that's the irony at that time. We have to promote our fullness to be accepted. But even if Chinatown's architecture is a somewhat authentic representation of the real thing, what a lot of tourists don't realize is. The fact that real people live there, and that it is a place actually that is for poor people. I mean, it is at its essence, a place where people come to live when they first
嗯，这就是当时的讽刺之处。我们必须宣扬我们的异国情调才能被接受。但即使唐人街的建筑在某种程度上是对真实事物的真实代表，许多游客没有意识到的是：真实的人们住在那里，而且它实际上是一个为穷人提供的地方。我的意思是，从本质上讲，这是一个人们刚来这里时，因为住不起其他地方、因为需要那里提供的服务而居住的地方。
get here because they can't afford to live anywhere else, because they need the services that are provided there. Bonnie Soi says, this is true of all the Chinatowns she studied. They're all portals of entry for new immigrants of a particular class, you know, working class immigrants who don't speak English. In fact, thanks to factors like rent control, zoning restrictions, and really active tenants' rights groups in the community,
邦妮·索伊说，她研究过所有的唐人街都是如此。它们都是新移民的入境门户，属于特定阶层，你知道，不会说英语的工人阶级移民。事实上，由于租金管制、分区限制以及社区中非常活跃的租客权利组织等因素，
San Francisco's Chinatown has managed to remain a relatively affordable neighborhood for low-income immigrants. And Bonnie says yes, Chinatown has been disneyfied and rebranded to cater to American tastes, but there's still an authentic and important history there. There's something about it that if you can sort of read the skyline, you can read the story of of how this place came to be, and also in that is Chinese American history, and in that there's like, there's this power in that, for sure.
旧金山的唐人街已经设法保持为一个对低收入移民来说相对负担得起的社区。邦妮说，是的，唐人街已经被迪士尼化并重新包装以迎合美国人的口味，但那里仍然有一段真实而重要的历史。它有这样一种特质，如果你能读懂天际线，你就能读懂这个地方是如何诞生的故事，其中也蕴含着美国华人的历史，毫无疑问，这里面蕴含着一种力量。
99% invisible was produced this week by Chelsea Davis and Katie Mingle with Sam Greenspan Avery, Jofman Kirk, Cole Stead, and me, Roman Mars. A version of the story was originally broadcast in the public radio history program Backstory. We are a project of 91.7K ALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxan, the beautiful architecture and interior firm in beautiful, beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. We're all on Twitter, Tumblr, Instagram and Spotify. You can listen to every single episode of 99% Radio to the end. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本周的《99% Invisible》由切尔西·戴维斯和凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）制作，参与人员还有萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）、艾弗里·乔夫曼·柯克（Avery Jofman Kirk）、科尔·斯蒂德（Cole Stead），以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。该节目的一个版本最初在公共广播历史节目《Backstory》中播出。我们是位于旧金山91.7KALW的项目，由位于加利福尼亚州美丽繁华的奥克兰市中心的精美建筑与室内设计公司Arxan的办公室制作。你可以在Facebook上找到并喜爱这个节目。我们在Twitter、Tumblr、Instagram和Spotify上都有账号。你可以收听《99% Radio》的每一集直到结束。来自PRX。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。